[Musique]
les seules du post c'est très simple il
y a cinq sauts des oat émis qui ont été
placés par notre réalisateur jérôme
revon donc c'est so i lya je vous le dis
tout de suite il y à un saut où il ya
des plumes un saut où il y avait eu un
saut il ya des larves ainsi la mousse et
un son où il ya du faux mur de la paix
sur le point sur les pme non mais c'est
rien ça je vais poser des questions sur
l'amour est dans le pré aux chroniqueurs
ici si vous avez la bonne réponse vous
choisissez un dos petits camarades qui
évolue à la boule tu te c'est maintenant
le saut à 100 200 300 400 et on n'a pas
sociaux
qu'est-ce qui est accrochée aux portes
torchon écrit marianne et vers la mettez
sur alors je n'en est pas moins vrai
vous n'avez pas la moindre idée
eh ben je voudrais d'une regarde allait
commencer à réfléchir à quelle sauce
vous a dû lui donner karine bien sûr on
regarde mal acquis la réponse
voilà c'est cette théorie oui un grillon
un grillon qui n'a rien à faire ici 3 il
se met sous le iii alors pour l'instant
il ne fait rien bon d'accord il attend
gentiment il attend le 3 galles et la
profession de jilin au nord parce qu'il
peut vous envoyer en plus donc penser
qu'à votre gueule la tunisie est elle
plus des cultes rice viticultrice cba
lierre ou éleveurs de bovins
je me souviens très bien qu'il ait des
viticultrices qu'au début elle leur
apprenait à tailler à mettre les tuyaux
d'arrosage dans les rênes des premières
émissions
vous êtes sauvé jean michel r je vais
choisir mon ami gilles expliqué il se
met sous tension car il se met sous
quêtes sont karim et 4 à mlle 4 904
alors christophe carrière voici votre
question sérieuse et cg67 ordinale c'est
une mauvaise réponse est passé à
l'illettrisme 9h10
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'une équipe de tournage qui
vient aussi tôt le matin et pistolet
rouge et d'aujourd'hui se regarde et on
la voit la vérification
mais même ce 19 heures est-ce que vous
avez eu de la chance de n'avoir que ça
son ami
[Applaudissements]
m
ap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]